some of you may remember that Donald
Trump is being sued by author e Gene
Carroll for defamation and for sexual
assault and this is all related to an
alleged encounter in the 1990s
truth is sometimes Stranger Than Fiction
we have now learned that Donald Trump
mistook an image
of e Gene Carroll for his own ex-wife
Marla Maples in a deposition that took
place at Mar-A-Lago last year now what
you know Trump has argued I wouldn't
have sexually assaulted Jean e Gene
Carroll because she's not my type
now a lot of people might react and say
I don't sexually assault people so it
doesn't matter what the woman looks like
because I don't sexually assault people
no okay fine Trump said I wouldn't have
done it because she's not my type fine
so the fact that he thought it was his
ex-wife suggests maybe she actually is
his type it's unbelievable there's a
Washington Post article by Shayna Jacobs
Trump thought photo of accuser was of
ex-wife during deposition
Donald Trump mistook his sexual assault
accuser e Gene Carroll for his ex-wife
Marla Maples when shown a photograph
from the 1990s in a deposition at
Mar-A-Lago last year potentially
undermining one of the common defenses
he has used to deny an attack Trump
who's being sued by Carol for defamation
and sexual assault stemming from the
same alleged encounter has repeatedly
said Carol is not his type suggesting an
assault could not have occurred because
he would not have pursued her
romantically that's Marla yeah that's my
wife Trump said when he was examined by
Carol's lawyer Roberta Kaplan in a new
selection of excerpts from the
deposition that was unsealed Trump's
blunder in a sworn deposition was
quickly corrected by his attorney Alina
Haba who told him it was Carol not
Maples Maples was Trump's second of
three wives Trump did not immediately
have a comment the black and white photo
at issue has been circulating since
Carol made the allegations detailing an
account in her Memoir of a forced sexual
act Trump has denied ever knowing her
said she's not my type okay we all know
that this is a stunning situation and it
if if this didn't deal with things as
serious as sexual assault we could all
just be laughing at it but one of the
ways that Trump has tried to dismiss
these allegations and dismiss and
undermine The credibility of EG and
Carol has been to say she's simply not
my type I'm not attracted to her I
wouldn't have been attracted to her in
the 90s he's basically saying she is not
desirable enough for me to even pursue
her never mind force myself upon her or
something like that
here we learn oh
an image of her in the 90s Trump
actually believed was his own ex-wife
someone who I would assume Trump was
romantically and sexually interested in
now the bigger problem of course is that
this entire line of reasoning
perpetuates some really horrible
societal stereotypes about women and
sexual assault and it when Trump
mistakes his accuser for his ex-wife it
not only continues to go along that line
which is like was she attractive enough
for Trump to sexually assault her or not
right which is like a crazy conversation
to be having but it also more generally
raises questions about whether anything
Trump says can be believed whether any
of Trump's defenses can be believed when
they might be based on complete
misapprehensions by Donald Trump
altogether
this is not the first time Trump has
been accused of sexual assault he has a
history of denying allegations
undermining The credibility with similar
statements not my type wouldn't have
done it that sort of thing I don't know
whether this is going to go anywhere but
Trump mistaking the accuser for his own
ex-wife is really wild wild stuff